AGGA des was once a crossroads for
ancient trading routes Tuareg salt
caravans used to pass through here today
this legendary desert city is a transit
hub for migrants and people smugglers
every week 2,000 Africans begin a
journey north with hopes of reaching
Europe accompanied by armed guards were
on the lookout for women on their way to
Europe there's no shortage of them here
but they're clearly reluctant to speak
with foreign reporters once a colleague
from a Nigerian TV station approaches
them two women agree to meet up with us
in the evening to tell their story
provided they remain anonymous I'm free
to go
one of them tells us her plan is to
travel from here to Libya and then to
Italy she says she knows Italy from
films and thinks it must be a beautiful
country country she's from Nigeria and
she's been here two weeks she does not
want to reveal who's helping her get to
Europe
she trusts only her roommate who grew up
here in the year and explains that more
and more women from Nigeria are turning
up in Agadez know and that is fine thank
you they don't stay long three or four
months at the most
they try and earn some money and then
continue on their way around 7:00 at
night they're all out on the street to
try and earn enough for a bite to eat
actually I'm lazy but when we ask about
people smugglers the women abruptly end
the interview there is evidence of
people smuggling all over Agadez a large
part of the local economy is based on
illegal Commerce with people fleeing
poverty in the last few years seven
banks have opened in the city and small
money transfer shops can be found on
almost every corner
the chaos in neighboring Libya plays
right into the hands of the people
smugglers here they can reach the
Mediterranean without strict border
controls the governor of Agadez
downplays the situation
he says the international community is
responsible for the problem Suhana
broken legion can't even see we often
restrain migrants from heading across
the desert when conditions are too
dangerous or when we know they want to
cross borders illegally for example to
work in prostitution novel sobriety I
need a CEO but at the moment there's
nothing we can do at the border but we
don't have enough resources is a
designer book we do my own pull Salaam
on the outskirts of town it's evident
that the government is doing little to
stop people smuggling locals have a name
for the overloaded trucks and vans
heading into the desert the Monday
convoy everyone here is familiar with it
but none of them can say how many of
these vehicles will actually reach the
Mediterranean